you're not going to be spared by life
you will always have to make one choice
understand that every second you delay
you are setting yourself back you are
further from accomplishing your goals if
you're trying to decide if I'm going to
do something or not and you keep putting
off the decision you've kind of made the
Nok decision
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan this channel
is designed to be a part of your daily
success routine and help you believe in
your Michael Jordan level talent so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message make a decision over to you go
or Gopal das where we are put in many
many complicated situations I want to
offer all of you a very powerful tool a
very simple one when you are talking
about making a choice weigh the
consequences and just decide which of
the two consequences you are okay to
bear moral dilemmas are easy to solve
because moral dilemmas are between good
and bad ethical dilemmas are hard to
solve because ethical dilemmas are
between bad and bad or good and good
remember this always you will have to
make one choice you're not going to be
spared by life you will always have to
make one choice choices means two things
to remember informed choices and
transformed choices we should make
informed choices what is an informed
choice is based on proper knowledge
based on proper deliberation based on
proper consideration based on proper
analysis not half is hardly whimsically
made choices and what is transformed
choices choice is based on a spiritual
strength so when we have a combination
of informed and transform then we make a
choice because Informant we know what
do but we can't do it unless we
definitely need to make transform
choices and therefore they say and an
elegant person will open your mind a
handsome person will open your eyes ah
quills asana recognize I mean but a
gentleman will open your heart a
gentleman who live in your heart and
what to speak of an intelligent handsome
gentleman this is what I appeal to all
of you become intelligent handsome
gentlemen your inability to make a
decision is the reason why you are stuck
where you are right now stop chasing
perfection and just decide because
success is not about perfection success
is about adjusting success is about
shrine launching starting and then
adjusting tweaking testing getting
feedback from the audience adjusting
adjusting adjusting and then you win
it's a story of every single successful
company Lamborghini started off selling
tractors Wrigley gum company started off
selling soap and baking soda
BMW started off selling airplanes look
at this channel look at this YouTube
channel that you are watching right now
I've had this channel for almost 10
years
the series that I'm most well-known for
the top 10 rules success series that
started just over three years ago I've
had the channel for almost ten years and
the top ten rule series started just
over three years ago every single series
that you have come to love and enjoy
this channel was not around when I first
launched this channel everything that I
started with is no longer here but I
started that's the key I decided I
started I had no idea what I was doing I
learned I try I test it I failed I
adjusted and I got better because
success is not about perfection
it's about adjustments now listen there
are people who are way smarter than me
who had a lot more talent than me for a
lot more money and resources than me who
could have started this channel they
could have started this channel they
could have done exactly what I'm doing
and have done it
but they are still sitting working at a
job that they hate and I have a channel
with 1.5 million subscribers
because I started I decided even though
I didn't have the perfect plan and they
didn't and that's not because I'm some
genius it's the exact opposite
they were smarter than me I won because
I started and you can too and so I
implore you if you are in that zone
right now where you're struggling this
side and you're worried about making the
perfect decision understand that every
second you delay you are setting
yourself back you are further from
accomplishing your goals stop chasing
perfection and start deciding and then
adjusting now I've got a really special
bonus tip that I think I'm gonna enjoy
but before that question today I want to
know what decision are you committing to
doing immediately after closing this
video let me now put it down in the
comments below
you can sometimes get by
down in making decisions and yeah I
think realizing that every decision not
made is a decision made because if
you're trying to decide if I'm going to
do something or not and you keep putting
off the decision you've kind of made the
not decision and and so you want you
don't want to be reckless with your
decision making but you also you want to
be data-driven but also realizing that
there's many decisions you have to make
where you don't have perfect data and
you never will and so one of the things
we're really you know driving in the
company is speed you know how can we
move quickly how can we reduce
bureaucracy and again working with
cruise automation you know one of the
things I have said as I've talked to
them is you know don't accept if the
company because we show up and we want
to help and you know we don't want to
get in the way of that that company
working but they've driven I'd say so
many positive things into the company
about moving with speed and what needs
to be done in a meeting or what can just
be done and so we're constantly looking
at that because you know being first is
an advantage and so that's what we're
really driving getting rid of the waste
making sure we move quickly
you know our leadership team we make
sure that we don't want to gate
decisions I mean there's many times
where early a global company early in
the morning or late at night we're on
the phone making a call so we don't stop
anything and I think the just the
mindset of knowing if them what longer
you take to make a decision again you
have to balance it of what data can you
get and and and maybe be data-driven but
if you just keep postponing something
you really have made a decision and
generally isn't gonna move your company
forward make decisions quickly so that I
can sell things quickly
because if you do it if you do it if you
do it a certain way you give yourself
permission to ask other people to do the
same thing
it's built in ethics but at the end of
the last year on December the for 13 to
14 captain rides in a room I said dude
we're gonna buy a plane by the end of
the year okay okay
I'm gonna wipe out my tax bill i'ma buy
damn plane and we're gonna wipe it out
okay I bought a plane in less than nine
days
brand-new plane in nine days the guy
Gulfstream says dude nobody does this
most people take nine months some people
take nine years they nine days both
plane bought it shopped it bought it
closed it he's like nobody doesn't stick
ridiculous huge purchase big purchase
typically a very long cycle a lot a lot
of shopping guarantee in that decision
that quickly would make me a lot of
money
you understand why now I make decisions
man so what do I expect you guys to make
decisions the same way I spent fifty
million bucks in freaking 90 minutes and
you guys take freaking nine months to
spend six grand
make decisions quick make decisions as
fast as you can stay certain you can get
new money everybody agree see when I do
that in my own life I could press you to
do the same thing I've given myself
permission and in this universe giving
myself permission to push people to do
things faster if you take a long time to
do things your bar will then be allowed
to take a long time to do things you
shop a second place a third plate the
fourth place a fifth place a sixth place
guess what they will too
you got to get a best deal cuz your
daddy taught you to get a good deal
never be taking advantage of shop to in
three places get your best discount it's
got to be on sale then guess what every
customer you have is gonna what give me
a deal man give me a deal man give me a
deal man okay your worst customers are
the ones you give the best deal to it
never can make them happy they want
something Oh give me something extra
give me something else oh the mooch
never satisfied right or wrong because
you guys are moochers
you got some muchas just be honest man
you can't fix what you denied you're a
mooch they're gonna be a mooch they're
cheap they're gonna be cheap you're
cheap they're gonna be cheap you take a
long time they're gonna take a long time
you shot four or five places they're
gonna do the same thing you need more
information they're gonna do the same
thing you got to have your wife involved
they're gonna do the same thing yes
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that people passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's something severe if you want
to learn more from go check out the top
ten rules video I did on him it's right
next to me continue to believe I hope
you enjoy today's shot a vinspresso and
I'll see you on the next video I want to
say one thing just one and probably this
will change the direction of your life